Alex thank you for joining us yeah this
is a lot of fun I really appreciate it
we're both part of the intelligent crazy
people group on Facebook that's how we
met mm-hmm
yeah it's good to be able to stop by
here in Boston and talk to you in person
yeah yeah we just finished up a crazy AI
in biotech conference on Thursday and
then we just did see over thena health
today and now we're gonna be talking to
you and I'm really excited to talk to
you
you've asked 53,000 questions on Quora
that's a lot of questions it's the
number-one amount of questions asked
that's crazy is that like 10 questions a
day or something once upon the time it
was 30 to 40 questions a day until
chorus Rado to ask questions by email
after which my rate shot down 30 to 40
questions a day and you would just
submit it via email because it was easy
you could just type up the question
press send and there to get an upload a
new profile yeah because it's very
similar to Twitter in that sense
whenever that thought comes to your head
you want to just tweet it out there and
see what people have to say or Quora ask
hold with that question yeah yeah and
your questions are really good actually
your profile page is very interesting
we'll put the profile on the URL but
it's just Cora Dom for slash profile for
slash Alex - Kay - Chen cagn and I
really enjoyed reading about what you
care about self-directed learning that's
so important tell us what you think
about that why is it about being picky
about what stimuli you encounter and
knowing what you learn well and what you
don't learn well and just going by and
learning teens in a way that you find
fun so you will want to actually refer
back to it later Rosen throw it out
later
and let's talk a little bit more about
being picky about what you learn because
I think this is becoming more and more
Gordan for young people to understand
because your brain is really molding
through your youth yeah and apparently
and if our if our parents are very
particular about what they expose their
children to at young ages maybe better
understanding the cosmos better
understanding evolution better
understanding the human anatomy human
spirituality self-actualization
playing with all these different types
of technologies that exist in the world
to figure out what we like what we want
to be most creative about at the
youngest age possible so how do you pick
what you learn so I think nowadays is I
try to optimize her material I learn
well super quickly and I find fun and
which ideally has some sort of structure
that I can refer to in the future and
that's probably relevant for people who
are probably aligned with me or who I
would get along as well which does not
necessarily correspond to what I
originally obsessed with earlier or a
sought-after word like because I used to
I used to honestly be obsessed with
learning curricular materials and then
trying to satisfy all the materials like
self-study ApS or look up the course
schedule for some arbitrary University
even though the universities curriculum
isn't the best gauge of what's important
or valuable and now I realize that in
the world where no one can learn
everything it's better to have unique
knowledge isn't common knowledge yeah
yeah that's a really good point right
there okay so we are very certain that
we're never going to learn everything
there's too much to learn to know
everything so because of that then
having common knowledge is both it's a
it's important because you want to know
that the Earth orbits the star right
it's pretty important common knowledge
right or maybe that your heart is
beating a hundred thousand times a day
to keep you alive
maybe the would you agree those are
important common knowledge points sure
okay but and by common knowledge I mean
themes that are probably more explicitly
in the curriculum rather than those
isolated facts okay so it be like when
you actually go to a classroom in what
you learn in the classroom is what all
30 of the kids in the class learn versus
if you go and you wander a little bit
outside of the curriculum and you find
the things that make you unique yeah
okay so out of the outside of common
knowledge so if you--if we're trying you
if you're trying to direct your time
towards finding unique knowledge how do
you do that one way to generate it
another way is look at the paper is no
one else is reading though they can be
idiosyncratic for example ed Boyden
suggests Forest radius that you looked
at papers and sentences from several
decades ago oftentimes with unique
knowledge today or what's unique
knowledge with wasn't unique knowledge
in the past more becomes unique
knowledge today as more and more people
are a bit addicted you prove them to
them oh yeah let's okay let's let's
unpack that a bit since we just wandered
their present ISM so that is the the
this this essence of living in today's
moment and and analyzing only
information that is visible to you today
on Facebook or on CNN or fox news or on
RT news or wherever you are in the world
you're just immersed in this present new
cycle versus if you dig up information
from five or ten or a hundred years ago
and you try and find unique knowledge
from back then yeah another I can't
present some simply publish or perish or
publish papers or write articles just so
that you can get your limits reached or
just so they can have something to write
or say rather than something that you
will sink people will still continue
reading and
10 to 20 years yes though data often
times is more timeless and papers and
there has been a trend of some
scientists to advocate for the
publishing of data rather than papers
and for segregate of the fabrication of
data of publishing between data
interpretation and visualizations ok so
then as you go to find knowledge that's
unique that is not present that is from
the past let's say how do you then dig
it up a lot of times through Google
that's a lot all the time through feedly
I follow a very ignorant aprotic set of
people on Twitter reddit kora and also I
often roamed around the college
libraries and then when you're looking
things up on Google or you're following
idiosyncratic people what are you
looking up and who are you following
I follow anything that new to me and
that also feels important and who is it
isn't baited by a culture culture wars
yeah ok and what do you mean by culture
wars stimuli that make you angry or
disgusted yeah okay and so then you're
you enjoy stimuli that does not make you
angry or discuss it and you enjoy other
people that don't follow that sort of
paradigm going towards that culture
culture wars yeah yeah and so then
you're the stimuli that you do prefer is
maybe a bit more idiosyncratic like you
said maybe things that people aren't
talking about is something that you
really enjoyed the black sheep
information ideally but this is not the
case all the time yeah okay all right we
we love the black sheep information for
example if you take a look at the way
that the political grid of gridlock is
going on in the United States people are
arguing over
issue that are just hitting heads versus
if you maybe go on immigration let's say
for an example or healthcare or whatever
and then if you maybe go all these
layers deep into immigration or into
health care or whatever you're trying to
dive into and you find one little
variable within the argument that
nobody's talking about but that you can
bring out into the light that can be
interesting but also an issue that's not
like immigration in health care where
it's 50/50 but let's say it's a
completely different issue where there's
ninety nine people think one way and
only one person thinks the other way do
you enjoy going into realms of thought
like that that are really contrarian if
you talk about really really contrarian
I think it's my you might say it's more
original than contrarian in itself yeah
I mean I posted a bunch of possible
contrarian sauce but it's but even then
a lot of people a number of people
egregious it's I think you do tend to
have a bit more concern if your valley
system is very high on maximizing for
creativity or your openness or
information gain as opposed to say
respect yeah mm-hm
so openness and information gain yeah
and being willing to just take in from
different sources and learn and be cool
with that and maximize for creativity
maybe you walk us through a couple of
the because I wanna I want to pull up a
couple of these other besides
self-directed learning other things that
I thought that you wrote that were
really interesting were that you care a
lot about increasing the amount of
people that were willing to try anything
why because people are afraid of doing
anything that's different and people who
are willing to try anything are like
they help change you in a good way
hopefully and I mean when people's
backgrounds are tend to be more
homogeneous
it just reads Altima theory is also not
exactly good and and then in the in the
future where emotions are being
automated yeah okay well we got a
bookmark that and talk about it later
okay but for now what would be a good
way to get people out of their comfort
zones and excited about trying things
that are different what are good
strategies for that so I know it's a
very common scene in adolescence of
course adolescents are often more
motivated by shock values and openness
so I also hysterical if motivated by
that I mean adrenalin rushes or just
sheer fascination
yeah I think it also means that they
have to feel safe if they depart from
the routines in order to in order to do
something different and also it's like
even if you would do things that are
different oftentimes like travel often
times what they do still follows
conventional routines or not routines we
can just Commission the scripts and
people somehow car for each other just
like people follow all these weird
scripts for what they expect in a
relationship which is really
constraining
so these scripts I really enjoy how you
call them scripts they're basically
algorithms their cultural algorithms and
their biological algorithm yeah yeah so
we have this drink water bladder full go
pee it's a biological script and we have
this cultural script which is maybe
something like in get text message read
text message text person back so there
are all these different scripts that we
have now that we follow and how can you
basically completely flip the script or
algorithm on its head there's a book up
in Peru which is basically applying the
improv games life which is basically
going the world assumption lists and hmm
figuring things out for yourself yeah
interesting because bacon which changes
yeah because the child is indoctrinated
into the world of all the
predispositions and culture and in
technology and all these things but if
you come in with in a state of improv a
state of play a state of just moving
things around flipping them on their
head and analyzing them and seeing what
happens as long as you're not killing
people don't don't do that don't be
violent but but doing things that are
different okay so how about these what
are your thoughts about maybe
systematizing creativity how can we do
that this is totally a work of AI
research I have a Cora answer on this
cool on what is creativity and so
there's creativity one is combinatorial
which is what people refer to as IDs X
just makes idea a was idea B II I'm so
happy that you just called it IDs X
because I call it networks X when I plug
people in together across different
fields to like work together or even in
the same field that didn't know about
each other call that network yeah you
can idea their note area are nodes in
the network yes continue yeah
yeah even ideas are nodes in the network
and then you were talking about
systematizing creature yeah yeah do you
want to unpack them yeah which is one
another way to some type it is to apply
abstractions from one area to another
area which is also kind of idea sexy I
mean there are several different
configurations we upon which you apply
idea sets from the simple my dudes hey
let's complain because let's combine
quantum quantum computing with machine
learning and then what's called quantum
machine learning or let's call it
blockchain plus dating or blockchain
plus anything else and that's the naive
approach idea sex but more sophisticated
approaches of ID effects would be so to
combine these ideas just and say just in
a more subtle nuts all the way
fine-grained way and give us an example
of one of those okay so let's say if you
combine do you need to do okay when
people people say uber for X for example
uber for food for groceries or uber for
give you things to deliver to your door
or uber for dating or uber for whatever
it has a certain meaning to it and I
mean the implementation it gets a
straightforward to most people as long
so you know the design stack which we
give it because the actions of one or so
easily apply that second to another
there are cases where true ideas are
still uncommon enough such that the that
said you can still combine one with the
other but only someone who is they
creative in a certain way and not text
book II would be able to understand it
would be able to combine them in a way
that a
since and be actually dozens in the
market yeah or attractive the people
that desirable or have some sort of
value so if you were to maybe teach kids
how would you teach them to be creative
and be self-directed learners yeah so
much of it might depend on the kids and
cells I'm not sure if all kids have the
potential to become self-directed
learners I'm not sure if curiosity is
and they'd a massive innate drive that
happens in each and every one kids even
though some unschooling people like to
say that does exist I'm not totally
convinced that it does mm-hmm but for
the ones for which the drive does I
think it supporting traffic
consequence-free failure it's important
for them to basically if they delve into
something that they're really good that
continued Contino doing it there might
be there might be some not just use in
case they get so fixed over something
that isn't really necessarily good for
them but only but preferably in a ways
that utilizes non-violent communication
and that doesn't discourage them from
seeking further feedback from you we get
a lot of times people are super
discouraged from seeking feedback from
you because you've criticized them in a
way that makes them uncomfortable and
averse to you from from now on yeah
correct
that's actually a really important key
as well as to know how to give really
good critique and to receive really good
critic oh I have totally noticed this
happen with a couple people lately yeah
all right how about we ask you about the
this art of the question because a lot
of people have answers or they think
they have answers or they speak a lot
listen a little they don't ask a
question one of the great ways to build
rapport with people is to be very gentle
and playful and loving and caring and
give them a good eye contact be an
active listener but
one of the most important things is to
be a good person to ask them questions
really good questions yeah
and by Kate questions I've done this
limine mind trip called knowledge out of
them but do it in a way that makes him
feel feel like they're about their value
that's not the parity but um just feel
like they want you answer it yeah I
think that it encourages them to show
them at the best show them at their best
yeah that's a good way to put it
your question will show them at their
best
will encourage them to speak at their
best so that is the importance of the
question do you have other aspects to
question asking that you want to share
with us that you think are really
important yeah so even though I asked if
you to sentence up questions in court I
regret I think you too many of them I
could have had all the same distinction
of accolades as I asked maybe twenty
five thousand two thousand fifty
thousand and had them better targeted
towards questions that people would
actually answer or questions that people
would actually be interested in and a
lot of my early questions showed how
childish I was when I joined Corps I
freaked Smith Wells else I found some
some like some childish scenes really
hilarious for example but that's not
those and the bulk of the questions I
think also I use to have a tendency to
purchase signal passing questions and
it's like it's also important to be
aware of say if your questions will
attracted answer isn't that both now and
in the future and the scope of the
audience that is available to answer it
and unfortunately Korra still hasn't
penetrated far beyond techniques yeah so
for example most of my questions
biochemistry totally remained unanswered
mmm-hmm I think all of us at one point
were 14 or 12 and just asking
ridiculously young and and and
both funny but also immature questions
and crude questions exactly and I even
still do today sometimes because they
just slip out because they're sometimes
I'd like to provoke people by asking
them crude questions yeah that's
important because we're being different
we like to catalyze the sense of
eccentricity and civilized people out of
their comfort zone and actually get them
more mindful and catch them off the
guard so that so they're not repeating
the same mental scripts all the time
exactly yeah I love that damn Alex this
is really fun I really good time you
only good time mmm cool how about we ask
you about some of these favorite
questions that you've asked yeah yeah
let's hear about that so one if new
professors remember the old research
papers they write hmm because they spent
so much of their time on these research
papers yeah and then do you remember
Lancer no not thoroughly if you'd be
surprised you see how a copy memory
isn't this good when you're a professor
if you were would say when your
undergrad and if this also illustrates
that for such my question and asking
that knowing everything shouldn't
necessarily be by say in Spenser
Greenberg's words a terminal or
fundamental value it should it it has
value in respect relation to something
else not really really not acid terminal
one I had a math function come up in my
head as we were discussing math and
information so from the moment that
you're born into something that I'm
writing a book about one of the chapters
of the book but this idea that from the
moment that you're born until the moment
that you die is a finite amount of time
yeah at least for now and because of
that finite amount of time there is also
a certain quality that we could ascribe
to information certain information is
war
more and it gives you closer to knowing
more than other information yeah totally
okay so then then the general idea is to
invest as much of your time as possible
into the highest quality information as
possible so that you can learn as much
as possible yeah that's why I learned
about life hacks a lot of the best
people are into life hacking or how to
structure their notes or how to
structure knowledge
yeah and even though sometimes some of
it sounds lame it's important gets right
the first time so you can you can most
painless you refer back to it later yeah
I'm actually gonna ask you probably
after this I mean I'm gonna show you my
Evernote oh I would love that and I'm
yeah because I have like almost 2000
notes and they're very disorganized and
you know I'll have someone else organize
them or provide the initial impetus for
you or at least organize a little bit of
it they're organized by like someone's
name or by a topic right and so I would
be interested to hear what your thoughts
are about how to best organize them how
about besides collegiate professors
writing papers and typically forgetting
about what they wrote about a couple
what years later years later or they can
have their students write it and they
might not necessarily know all the fine
details of it what other what are their
favorite questions I have a list of a
request in the Quora so we pull it up
yeah we should all right let's do it
okay so yes I can't I can't exactly
recall all my favorite questions top of
my head now now that I've sum of years
on the in kora
so this is why I post mm-hmm I'm in a
separate board for example it's the role
of dopamine and motivation separate or
independence from the roles dopamine
works memory given that dopamine is a
crucial part in both aspects
and they might be an opening different
pathways may be responsible for each and
it's not that many neuroscientists on
Quora to help you there are some nearest
sites have better representation cores
and many other topics but it's still way
way way too for you like if you read it
it has a larger representation of
neuroscientist except the log people are
experienced read it burn out too it's
like there's a I think there is a sort
of collective burn Altamont core rather
than Stack Exchange and the burnout is
from what would you say I think it's the
sense that they probably spend too much
effort on core for how much they were
rewarded or appreciated for it which
sometimes comes in when you say expect
expect people to be more appreciative of
what you do and then you say you see
other people write [ __ ] your answer is
they get it and crumb or Cara please
make simpler answers it garner thousands
of up votes yeah you might write a
that's totally true on my reddit account
I've written complex answers and complex
questions that have gotten one or ten
upvotes
versus ones of like I took a picture of
a water fountain that reads those water
bottles with without needing to inkle
the bottle the one that saves plastic
yeah and then that got like ten thousand
up votes and so there's even my own case
study of such an interesting difference
between people needy and get valued they
need to hear from their tribe that the
answers that they're giving are
meaningful questions yeah and also the
timelessness of read it read read a
poster just over a very hard to search
for it's hard to highlight your best
reddit post to other people yeah and
I've also seen it a phenomena where a
lot of coin oh no longer use any of
those sites even they use now I don't
even know what the hell they use did you
see with real life a little bit of that
and there's also some Twitter and
Facebook but neither of those ideal and
then a lot of people are now moving to
these
private groups like this intelligent
crazy people group yeah probably there's
been definitely been a movement towards
private groups yeah
okay how about another maybe give us
another one or two of these questions
that are some of your favorites that
you've asked what about your top
uploaded question
oh god once upon a time I probably
remember it
I mean well top follow questions your
content let's check that out yeah all
right look at stats it's probably some
really really simple question like so if
I look at my most viewed
and also the value gets from app from
doing stuff on Quora it's not exactly a
linear function of the time you invest
in it it's more like a sub linear
function with or a logarithmic function
with some peaks to surprise you and it's
taking a while to load
do you remember off the top of your head
at least somewhat of a popular question
okay so yeah and you are teasing of my
memory here because I think my memory
for this comments also not if you get
stronger it was even though it's like
with the [ __ ] with last 30 Dave you look
at all time what does it let you have a
brother that's a good question though
what's it like to have a brother because
there's a lot of people is this very
subjective answered a lot of people say
I love having a brother a lot of people
would say that I don't like having a
brother some people would say that it
was an incredible experience growing up
with a sibling yes yeah there's all
these different ways to view it and then
the second one the second and third ones
wait second third and fourth ones are
slightly transgressive questions let's
hear what's advantages of having a low
GPA what is the one advantage of having
a low GPA advantages of having a low GPA
yeah Wow it goes like counter to what
everyone else has been towed and yeah I
mean sometimes low GPA people are the
most creative people Oh totally because
they don't fit into the box of the
education system and there's like even
even after you have a high GPA little
it's very difficult to learn a lot of
those habits yeah or especially if one
is guilt motivated which some people
aren't and some people are and then what
about the next couple just keep going if
it common for Google employee to sleep
overnight in the Googleplex
huh and what did you remember any of the
answers to that yes they yes it is and I
think especially in the early days I'm
not sure the weather is encouraged or
super discouraged but I mean when people
work super hard
I think we're hard they have culture
they produce a a kosher food and
overnight switch and sometimes who even
celebrate it
yeah of working really hard to try and
achieve the goals yeah yeah working on
and it can be good if the goal is like
NASA legit goal but when it's a non
legit girl if you bring you out long
term it's cute too
let's um give us a run to give three
let's just read through the questions
quick every more three more where did
some particularly creative way that
students cheat Wow
whether the most common reason so I
software engineers get fired okay what
is the craziest scene you have ever seen
or written in a resume or CV nice how
corrupt is Microsoft
how does Elon Musk remember what he
reads uh-huh what is it like to be
pregnant and underage oh wow what is the
easiest way to ruin your entire life in
one move wow these are very interesting
questions I can totally see why you're
gaining a lot of attraction to people
wanting to answer these yeah I have
actually tried some of those evie truly
during your life in one move and they're
totally not worth it unless you have
support but like support like their or
even your even building up empathy for a
woman that might or a girl that might
have gotten pregnant underage yeah yeah
you're building up empathy in this way
that's so interesting
okay how about we let's let's let's end
the show by asking you a couple of the
questions that we usually ask our guests
okay okay now
you balance this inner self
actualisation in the dry fort along with
the inner drive of the collective
actualization oh this is something I'm
trying to figure out better over time
because I used to I used to aim
primarily for individual self
actualization although I fig nose way I
virtual signaled a desire to help others
even though it does it wasn't
necessarily in my innate drive simply
because I lived on a certain competitive
hierarchies and also I was angry at my
own schools were holding me back
so I mean anything publicly that school
made me do I would be extremely
resentful for but but now I realized
someone has the freedom and agency to
self actualize a lot of times when you
have other when you when it helps in the
pursuit when helping other people they
can also help feel their energy and
you're helping yourself actualize and
they can give you feedback and which
also helps especially since I often have
cycles of very low energy or depression
which makes me more dependent on other
people then I wish I was but which I
have to face yeah and then so this like
urban flow between the two how do you
get to a state of feeling like you're
both investing really good time in your
own actualization but also helping bring
value to the collective oh yeah yeah and
that's I think if writing scenes that
are relevant to other people or that say
other people can provide meaningful
comments on because if I do it just on
myself then it's a one-man army and I am
I'm not exactly increasing my chances of
stay self sustainability or I mean
ultimately my main goal is self
sustainability and yeah yeah if every
person's goal is self sustainability but
then also sustainability of the
collective I mean
in a really good position yeah yeah
totally how about we ask you about the
this is gonna be a couple there's gonna
be multivariate question we're gonna
pull on a couple different subjects here
but we're gonna see if we need to unpack
them individually or how you do it but
all right currently we're going through
a phase of massive technology across so
many different industries and it's kind
of exacerbating wealth inequality we
have lots of access to AI and robotics
maybe biotechnology and these upgrades
for ourselves space colonization these
different ways that people can now
cryptocurrency earn more for themselves
that already have a lot let's say but
you think also if you look at the number
absolute number of people in extreme
poverty if you look at say Steven
Pinker's argument yeah sure so although
the Pinker argument is true but we are
exaggerating wealth inequality my
question is how do you think we will end
up working together to try and fix that
or solve it or do you potentially see an
a class-based exacerbate or a classmate
speciation occurring I think we're going
to have to realize that some people's
object level desires and made a level
desires may fundamentally conflict with
each other if they're given more of the
truth and people should not attach too
much of n-terminal value to being better
than other people or being superior to
other people and and for those who vow
structure lives in those metrics I think
it's that better to figure out how they
can still achieve other needs without
having to be better than others so
although not everyone if necessarily
that's not necessary it that was
openness to same extent that I do I see
you still possible for the other
attributes like love for meaning that
doesn't if they'll have truth some
hierarchies definitely how about how do
we work together across the world for
globalization with the United States and
China and Russia and with AI and
biowarfare and okay this is a
complicated question
I believe it it requires a sense of
trust and the problem is people don't
know if they'll trust each other and
that's why they are so paranoid of say
Facebook having access to their data or
Google having access to the data and
then maybe
how would you foresee that trust coming
together across the world so that we
could progress collectively as a planet
for one theme we need to be in posts put
post scarcity we also have to make sure
that people don't have desires that are
super super unrealistic for example
overly materialistic desires such as
having a huge home with a huge lawn that
needs a high amount of maintenance or
eatin all the meat that you want you
when the world can system we can't
sustain there's many animals plus people
and then add a couple more homes and a
couple more boats and a couple more
jewelry items and then yeah finally
there yeah post scarcities importance
also you're going to have to get
people's desires for anger and revenge
also ameliorated because though I don't
think those should be anyone stead of
fundamental desires so they might a
slice them a soft level level ones and
you're just gonna figure out a way to
validate their sinking or transfer thing
to do something that's healthier without
making them feel like it's being forced
on them absolutely yep okay how about
what is the deepest emotion that you've
ever felt oh god oh god
so I say childlike immersion in new
environments like what winter scenes
that make me happy there's a question
about asking for such a good answer
childlike immersion in new environments
but the tech Mahama
yeah yeah those two you just listed two
major ones yes and the in the trauma did
I to prove my south proof in middle
school
prove certain people wrong
just extend just Gillison true of my
feet and to my compulsive desire to
learn as much as I can which also
resulted in me not gonna say the
selecting the best materially from how
about we unpack that initial answer in
just a little bit more detail what was
the feeling that you experienced when
you learn something that expanded your
mind to these new dimensions
oh man fascination - fascination
fascination if just I want I want to
read more with have explosion and also
sometimes wouldn't win if I don't feats
in with social validation like they're
really happy so most of my times I want
to join new social networks like Korra
or reddit or agent parts - or having
games or say other environmental first
time or sometimes theoretically if you
have the whole world to explore at the
same time what would you say is the most
beautiful thing in the world
that's the depends on how you define
beauty the times on the sides of I'll
see my something happen exposed you also
depends how can train one wants to be
and he's so good okay but get but give
us maybe give us your most contrarian
than answer a Peter teal is the most
beautiful thing in the world I'm I just
have to answer this way regardless of
whether it's beautiful but a backpack
space taxis um in reality look a few
teeth but you know I have to ask you why
you said that now because he is
contrarian and sometimes he is like one
of the most simple expense everyone's
imaginings with possible bite for moms
shells except for I'm not sure if he has
done it in the last five years cookie
was better earlier unless he's doing
something very secretly she is doing a
lot of things very sick
right now and I think hopefully they'll
be exposed to the world and benevolent
ways in the next couple yeah yeah
totally totally peeps on people infant
and my wall hypothesis kills traumatized
and be traumatized and because of that
they think he only cares himself or his
own immortality and maybe they they
think you're here should have a little
bit more empathy except there's some
reason why he's not showing much of it
and they wonder why all right how about
we asked you about the existential
threats that kind of face civilization
right now are you concerned about
humanity reaching a Fermi filter and not
progressing any further I'm probably
concerned but not to the fifth and one
level yeah and does your concern stem
more from AGI or bio warfare or wealth
and quality or awareness nuclear war
geopolitical mayhem where does it stem
from I think violet who warfare could be
well given that it might be incredibly
incredibly easy to craft yeah contagious
viruses that may in fact wipeouts 100
lots of people Alex what do you plan on
doing in the next couple of years like
what do you care about building into the
world more improving I still have like
some basic health issues that I have to
work on with translation my energy
issues and also feats and should my past
trauma and sleep apnea but it's like
it's still an open question because like
because I'm curious on every scene but
in the other hand no I cancel earn
everything so I just have to figure out
wit where which people would best
appreciate me my energy and also be
friendly true my kind of learn sound
personality where I'm free to engage and
disengage intention that will and where
say interests yeah yeah
that you're free to engage and disengage
your attention at will so then I that's
a pirate that's part of Internet oh
that's a power of the Internet correct
totally but at the same time in
in-person conversations a lot of people
already do engage and disengage by
grabbing their cellphone in the middle
of conversation in person I don't think
it's a bad thing yeah I don't think it's
a bad thing either I just think that we
already do that in in this way all right
how about we I think the optimal mode of
conversation of people is awesome just
go into the same room and just working
so laptop together and then just laying
ransom the pop in their head Oh totally
and then there's no expectation of say
force or demand or FOMO yeah yeah that's
already happening so much um you also
brought up the about what you're about
you're working on and what you want to
build that you're kind of you know we're
focusing on your health that's really
important and do you and you're focusing
on good people and good energy did you
feel like you had a good time in
conversation today yeah yeah I hope that
important except they don't have free
time yeah I hope that we can surround
ourselves with people that care more
about the things that were talking about
and more that will expand our minds and
that will expand them to new dimensions
of thought that make us more intelligent
that hopefully build a better world I
really appreciate you a lot Alex Chen
yeah thank you so much for coming onto
the show didn't really appreciate it and
your I think your mind has a lot of
further potential to share with this
planet and I really look forward to it
yeah it's one of my regrets them that I
haven't done a better good job of
sharing it or documenting better and
documenting the stuff that I'm uniquely
Basia documenting which is it not
exactly the stuff I originally obsessed
over pursued and maybe there's a way to
synergize on that and help each other
with
thank you Alex thanks everyone for
tuning in greatly appreciate it thanks
Ron vargas are producing partner yeah
thank you yeah thank you Ron and we'll
catch you guys more soon